[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
nouvelle édition d' espace autochtones
en direct merci de nous retrouver pour
parler cette semaine des enfants
autochtones donc pour parler des droits
des enfants pour parler aussi du soutien
qui est accordée aux enfants pour parler
des soins de santé aux enfants ça va
nous amener entre autres chez les inuit
avec mes collègues aujourd'hui charles
bonjour charles bronson charles votre
sujet vous ne touche pas aux enfants du
tout on va parler d'une artiste très
connu
de plus en plus connu autant chez les
autochtones que les non autochtones tout
à fait exactement on va parler d'un
artiste qui était invité à la biennale
de white n'est whitney la new york
d'accord et puis avec élise bonjour
éligible en juin mais alors elisha on va
parler dans de la protection des enfants
inuits on va parler plus
particulièrement des soins accordés aux
enfants inuits avec vous oui le soin de
santé puis la particularité qui existe
dans les territoires absolument
et puis on parle de la du projet de loi
ses 92 en fait il est baptisé loi
concernant les enfants les jeunes et les
familles des premières nations des
inuits et des métis
ça c'est un projet de loi qui avait été
annoncé l'automne dernier par l'ancien
ministre des services aux autochtones
john philpot elle a été remplacée par
seamus o'regan et donc c'est monsieur
o'regan qui a déposé ce projet de loi
hier on était jeudi un projet de loi
dont qui change un peu la donne
concernant les enfants autochtones donc
pour parler de ce projet de loi pour
parler de ce qui est bien dans le projet
de loi est peut être moins bien on va
rejoindre à wayne dac et donc près de
québec gino lesage il est conseillé aux
programmes en éducation spéciale du haut
conseil de l'éducation des premières
nations bonjour bonjour ou alors vous
êtes coup et oui vous êtes en skaï peut
vous êtes installé à wendake et d'abord
jean lesage on va expliquer un peu le
projet de loi dont ce que dit le projet
de loi c'est que l'on va donner plus de
responsabilités aux communautés
autochtones donc on leur céderait le
contrôle de la protection de l'enfance
ça c'est un des points également ce
qu'on veut faire c'est de réduire le
nombre d'enfants qui sont placés en
famille d'accueil
on mise aussi sur la prévention en
accordant la priorité aux soins
prénataux et en accordant la priorité à
des programmes d'éducation et de soutien
aux parents notamment donc ça concerne
ce que vous faites au haut conseil en
éducation des premières nations
comment est-ce que vous accueillez ce
projet de loi vient tout d'abord au cpn
on accueille quand même assez
favorablement le projet de loin c'est
qu'à travers ses 92 on considère une
avancée positive au niveau des relations
avec les premiers peu le passionnant au
niveau 2 des enfants
toutefois en fait on se demandait ce que
est ce que tout ça va suffire d'un sens
où on croit qu'un financement adéquat
devra suivre nécessairement ne serait ce
par exemple que pour répliquer le
contrôle la protection de la jeunesse
dont les communautés seront responsables
de ça et on s'en réjouit mais encore est
ce que l'argent va suivre ça va
nécessiter nécessairement des ressources
supplémentaires pour les communautés et
peut-être même aussi de la formation
on ne reçoit possède ce contrôle comme
ce jour où l'homme est une manière
facile
donc c'est une préoccupation qu'on nous
excuse je n'ose pas on pourra suivre
pour que le contrôle puisse se faire au
niveau des premières nations
monsieur lesage qu'est ce qui se déroule
actuellement sur le terrain là parce
qu'évidemment vous êtes proche des
enfants conseil en éducation des
premières nations
c'est quoi la réalité actuelle des
enfants des premières nations bien c'est
une réalité qui vend sa d'épargné comme
on tue son emploi tout ça même réalité
mais je vous irez surtemps communautés
éloignées
on parle de conditions pauvres et si le
projet de loi en fait de l'esprit de la
loi direction de la prévention
il va falloir que l'état s'engage
formellement vraiment s'attaquer aux
problématiques de pauvreté notamment au
niveau du logement une surpopulation
dans des logis vous voulez communauté
autochtone 1 ouvre on est prêt au niveau
du monde de l'éducation et près des
écoles et on se rend compte que
plusieurs écoles surpeuplées des écoles
nous a fait des écoles 18 qui sont avec
moi donc encore le financement devra
suivre également la problématique de la
jeunesse c'est quand même majeurs par
exemple des communautés où on ne les
sculptait à loger les membres des
communautés et quand on veut engager du
personnel enseignant ou des
professionnels pour venir aider les
élèves les enfermant cordon de la
problématique du logement et parfois
avec communautés sont aux prises avec le
dilemme est ce qu'on n'accorde tous deux
font la joie au moment où la population
est à un temps on doit aussi penser à
accueillir du personnel enseignant
professionnel pour pouvoir aider ces
mêmes enfants
oui et ça c'est une autre difficulté
aussi un oui tout à fait tout à fait
parce que bon on se pose on veut aller
travailler juste pas moi qui sait à qui
cohabitent joie n'y a pas
d'infrastructures pour accueillir la
personne et c'est une problématique
importante et même je vous ai rien d
embrouille obodou il n'y a pas
d'électricité entre l'abitibi
l'école fonctionne avec une génératrice
il n'y a pas d'électricité pas d'eau sur
la communauté donc les jeunes vivent
dans des conditions de pauvreté
j'irai pas extrêmes être le pauvre était
importante et elle ont pas les mêmes
chances que les autres élèves en ce sens
là au niveau de la pauvreté que les
élèves ou ailleurs chez les non
autochtones au canada au québec
oui et puis enfin non les ir
ouais c'est que je crois qu'elle le
problème de fond c'est vraiment une
question de forme à combattre la
pauvreté va falloir vraiment régler la
problématique de logements les écoles
également le besoin d'agrandir ou bâtir
de nouvelles écoles commission s'attaque
pas à ces questions-là de fond à ce
point d'inspirer de fond dans le projet
de loi oui c'est intéressant mais pour
qu'il soit opérationnel au niveau des
communautés bien vu d'énormes pots
seulement de l'argent devra être
investie mais toutes sortes de mesures
devront être prises pour s'attaquer à
ces problèmes ainsi que oui
d'ailleurs nous allons recevoir un petit
peu plus tard daniel vandal il est
secrétaire parlementaire du ministre des
services aux autochtones donc seamus
o'regan et c'est une question que vous
aurez pour lui un savoir est ce qui aura
un financement adéquat qui va pouvoir
suivre parce que c'est bien de dire
voilà on vous donne la responsabilité de
vos enfants
mais s'il n'y a pas les fonds
nécessaires pour stabiliser la réalité
des jeunes on n'est pas plus avancé oui
oui et puis ça pourrait aussi amener les
premiers pas dans une soixante arras en
tout six posons les moyens ne suivent
pas au niveau financier ou autre et
qu'elle agit comme nous et ça se vend un
v10 cette responsabilité là mais vous
n'êtes pas capable d'assumer ça nous
avance pas beaucoup en effet c'est ce
que disait d'ailleurs cindy blackstock
je rappelle qu'elle est la directrice
générale de la société de soutien à
l'enfance et à la famille des premières
nations du canada et est régi réagissez
à ce projet de loi c'est 92 est elle
aussi c'était sa grande inquiétude a il
faut que les financements suivent ce
qu'on donne ce qu'on impose aux
communautés dans sa voiture et lui
revient qui contraint le gouvernement à
s'engager financièrement ce niveau la
lune un appel ou financement mais il y
aura un petit double hijran en fédérale
uniquement même des fonds donc c'est un
beau projet dont on l'accueille
favorablement mais faudra voir comment
tout ça va être trop professionnaliser
le coma le financement quelle serait
pour vous les changements souhaités et
un projet de loi mais mais si vous
pouviez de votre côté année des conseils
pour les changements souhaités sur le
terrain dont dans les communautés ce
serait quoi exactement
d'abord écouter les communautés l'écouté
ce qu'ils ont dit qu'elles ont besoin et
font leur besoin est là pour éviter
l'arrivée aussi dans une posture un peu
impérial et souvent voilà on veut
établir avec vous une relation d'égal à
égal mais soudée par l'association les
pauses et gagne c'est difficile pour une
première nation de se positionner comme
dans un rapport d'égalité ou d'abord les
coutures pressent leurs besoins
qu'est-ce qui est les besoins et les
réalités diffèrent d'une communauté une
autre on peut pas non plus abordé la
question des premières nations au québec
par exemple manière homogène la réalité
n'est pas par elle d'une communauté halo
donc ça va être important d'écouter les
communautés pour qu'elles puissent
allemagne décider comment ils veulent
mettre en oeuvre les différents
application de la loi
c92 et c'est à elles au fond de
s'exprimer moi je pourrais pas de zéro
au nom de tout le continent
je pourrais pas dire le nom de ces
communautés de bain voici ce dont on
vous la manière générale chaque mini
comme monter sa réelle tpr a donc ce
sera au gouvernement vraiment d'écouter
les communautés les organisations
régionales comme la nôtre parce qu'on
représente
c'est comme une autre mais ça va être
important de du coup les déficits et
chacune montée mais ce n'est pas une
approche qui a déjà été fait parce que
l'on présente un projet de loi dont on
est quand même avancé dans le processus
c'est pas une approche qui a déjà été
fait que ce soit auprès de votre conseil
auprès des autres organismes qui
s'occupent des des soins aux enfants
ah oui je crois que ça a déjà été fait
mais c'est pas rassurant parce que les
choses doivent changer rapidement un
projet de loi bon avant qu'une loi entre
en fonctions ça va encore prendre un
certain temps mais déjà il faut qu'on
puisse amorcer du travail sur le terrain
oui tout à fait et puis si quelques
jours j'imagine qu'on compte atteint
très compliqué à ce niveau là mais c'est
clair que la musique sion devra les
champions de france poursuivrait
et pendant pendant plus oppressif se
précipiter dans l'application de ce
projet de loi là oui absolument
dino lesage merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
réagi donc à la présentation de ce
projet de loi c'est 92
nous aurons sûrement l'occasion de vous
reparler parce que vous allez suivre de
très près donc les prochaines démarches
et dans quelques instants je vais
pouvoir poser votre question aux
secrétaires parlementaires également
donc est ce qu'il ya des sous c'est ce
que vous voulez savoir restera des des
fonds pour pour aider à l'implantation
de ces changements pour que ça soit
passé de d'actualisation sur un niveau
local oui dino le sage je rappelle que
vous êtes conseiller aux programmes en
éducation spéciale au conseil en
éducation des premières nations
avant de vous quitter j'ai une autre
question parce que je sais que vous
connaissez très bien le principe de
jordan un principe qui donc touche les
jeunes enfants des premières nations
expliquez nous et hop à ce qu'on va en
parler dans quelques minutes
expliquez-nous ce qu'est le principe de
jordan en fait le principe d'autres
jeunes
historiquement c'est venu pour appuyer
les les enfants autochtones
même le même niveau services que ceux
qu'on aime un mot de l'homme
on retrouve dans des provinces à
l'intérieur du canada parce qu'il y
avait des disputes en différentes
juridictions c'est un début octobre lors
du petit jordan ou le plan fédéral et
provincial les coûts pour donner des
services des soins de santé à cet enfant
alors qu'ils n'ont pu retourner chez lui
j'ordonne pour ce petit garçon un petit
garçon qui s'appelle john anderson c'est
lui en fait qui a été qui a donné le nom
à ce principe parce que c'est lui qui a
eu à vivre cette réalité là tout à fait
et il est décédé à l'hôpital parce que
les gouvernements provinciaux ou
fédéraux ne sont ne se sont pas
prononcés le général ne seront pas
entendre
sûr qu'ils devaient payer les pensions
donc le jeune est décédé avait pu temps
sans pouvoir retourner chez lui dans sa
communauté et par la suite
quelques années plus tard du un jugement
de la cour qui vraiment obligé de vendre
en fédérale a donné le même niveau de
services aux enfants des premières
nations aux enfants bennati et même au
delà d'un sens où à cause des préjudices
historiques notamment les pensionnés en
disant que cette erreur et on a parfois
donné un niveau de service encore
supérieur étant donné que les séquelles
et dirigiste aurait construit les
premières nations les horizons où
beaucoup nui au niveau de leur
développement chez les enfants et qui
faisait que se tenait bon et maintenant
le procès d'aujourd'hui net opérationnel
une maison et ils se terminent les
initiatives actuel prend fin au 31 mars
donc à partir du 1er avril et devrait y
avoir autre chose c'est sûr que le
financement vont rester le principe de
jordan disparaître c'est vraiment une
obligation de la part du gouvernement
fédéral mais on sait pas quelle forme ça
va prendre dans la vie prochaine nous
avons au niveau du financement est ce
que ça vous à l'heure actuelle c'était
comme un projet pilote où on recevait
toutes les demandes et on est financé à
peu près tout mais on ne sait pas pour
le futur est ce que ça va prendre la
forme d'un programme
quel genre de financement seront
accordés à ce niveau là oui on n'est pas
là où le président de john s'applique
donc aux soins de santé des enfants aux
soins de s'hydrater
mais damas ont évolué ducation oui c'est
ce que j'allais dire oui il doit
s'appliquer aussi en ce qui concerne
l'éducation
tout à fait au programme d'éducation
spéciale qui couvrent quand même une
bonne partie des services des besoins
des élèves ont besoin qu'on appelle à
coûts élevés et le principe de jordan
peut venir conclut bonifié g là parce
que on s'entendra de l'argent nécessaire
spéciale et parfois rapidement dépenses
et au niveau les écoles donc j'ai passé
un peu venir compléter vos skis du
manque à gagner et nous devons laquelle
on tente d'harmoniser les pratiques
entre les principaux de la prestation de
services entre les écoles et les
services de santé services sociaux
notamment au niveau du communauté
protéines d'applications de services ou
de l'évaluation et c'est encore assez
d'audience est intéressant l'argent est
donnée rapidement mais s'arrête pas
toujours le problème de trouver les
ressources appropriées et ce sont
souvent des ressources extérieures donc
sont pas nécessairement familière avec
la réalité autochtone sont engagés le
rapidement pour rendre service et au
service du tout mais faut quand même pas
oublier qu'une évaluation par exemple
fait selon des standards occidentaux
introduit un biais un culturel qu'il y
avait eu le temps d'évaluer un enfant
donc y aussi ces problématiques liées
aux affaires et à ceux d'aujourd'hui
bon c'est bon pour moi au niveau
financier au niveau est quand même du
financement mais par contre présente un
défi ou harmonisé au niveau là
voilà merci pour toutes ces explications
monsieur lesage merci beaucoup et à une
prochaine sur le plateau d' espace
autochtone au revoir les niches c'est
intéressant on part du principe de
jordan il ne s'applique pas chez les
inuit
non et c'est ça s'était très médiatisée
en 2018
parce que les inuits sens à leur
applique pas du tout pourquoi mais c'est
un peu compliqué c
je peux rendre dans tout ça c'est très
technique mais qu'ils ont fait en
septembre 2008
c'est les inuits semaine le couvert par
un programme qui s'appelle l'enfant
d'abord alors maintenant ils sont
couverts mais c'est qu'en période parce
qu'ils sont en train de maintenant de la
braye un cadre qui est juste pour les
inuits qui veut juste les a nourris
accords qu'ils ont quelque chose
semblable eux mêmes et se c'était
quelque chose qui était supposée de
sortir entre décembre 2018 et février
qui vient de passer mais on en a pas que
de nouvelles mais c'est travaillant
colada sous pour avoir quelque chose
semblable qui s'applique aux inuits dans
les quatre régions inhumé du canada
hockey dont elle s est toujours en
attente et on va voir ce qui se passe ça
devrait prendre encore plusieurs mois
est ce qu'on sait combien de temps ça
peut presser peut-être aujourd'hui on
peut parler avec monsieur vandal pour
avoir c'est la réponse à ces questions
mais ceux qui étaient comme je dis qu'on
a commencé de parler de ça ou de beaux
débuts de 2018
ils n'étaient pas connus mais ils ont
trouvé phares sont depuis septembre avec
le l'initiative de franck d'abord oui
qu'ils soient couverts maintenant on
attendait que les cadres et qui vise les
animaux est soit soit terminé d'accord
alors quelles sont les différences là
entre les programmes offerts aux
premières nations les programmes aux
inuit
un autre invité là donc on va se tourner
vers lui tout de suite
daniel vandal bonjour bonjour structures
etc oui merci je rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire parlementaire du ministre des
services aux autochtones seamus o'regan
merci d'être avec nous alors vous avez
entendu hier et vous étiez j'imagine pas
très loin du ministre o'regan lorsqu il
a présenté le projet de loi c 92
à votre avis qu'est-ce qu'il va changer
ce projet de loi est ce qu'il est ce
qu'il va révolutionner quelque chose
dans la réalité des enfants autochtones
c'est certainement un seul
l'espérance a premièrement dire que tous
les jours à travers le canada il ya un
enfant tonnes il ya peut-être des
douzaines et même des centaines
d'enfants clapton qui sont séparés de
leurs familles leurs communautés à leur
langage leur culture et puis il sait les
enfants adaptant ne représente plus que
50 % de toutes les enfants qui sont en
garde
mais en même temps les enfants
autochtones devraient plus longue 8 %
des enfants qui sont 15 heures vous - à
travers le canada s'est fait que c'est
vraiment une crise qu'il faut qu'on
adresse
et puis à ceux ci quelques succès
d'harry son clip pourquoi qu'on avance
avec ce projet de loi et pour répondre à
la question c'est qu'avec l'introduction
du projet ce projet de loi ce ça
rendrait finalement à loi ça mettra
finalement endroit qu'est ce que les
nations métis autochtone premières
nations demain le gouvernement prendra
des décennies savoir s'abandonner les
nations autochtones ne pouvoir de ça va
fermer nos juridictions à général pourra
pour que le décider la manière meilleure
manière de de gérer propos de la
meilleure manière de faire qu'est ce qui
est mieux pour leurs enfants leurs
familles leurs communautés
oui alors donc ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
retire cette responsabilité aux
provinces on la donne aux communautés s
quel financement qui va suivre pour
permettre aux communautés de pouvoir
finalement donné les ressources le
soutien nécessaire aux enfants acteurs
absolument première chose c'est que
c'est un pantin le conecs depuis qu'on
était comme devenue élue en 2015 on eu
presque doublé en à bugeat pour des
services à l'enfance et la famille à
cape town à travers le canada
maintenant on dépense environ un point
dur milliards surtout de ses services
90 % 90 90 % de ces fonds sont dépensés
sur un appréhension des enfants puis
juste 20 % juste 20 % pour la prévention
se fait que donne le pouvoir aux
nationaux tâtonne pour refaire leur
système en utilisant leur propre poids
en utilisant leurs propres standards à
médoc se promettent l'enfer sur la
prévention la culture leur langage mieux
utiliser les familles immédiates au tour
puis les communautés immédiat autour
et puis ça fait vraiment premièrement on
refait le système il va avoir une
différente manière de délivrer les
services à l'enfance et les femmes est
fait c'est difficile a vraiment a
confirmé un chef d'argent avant qu'on
sait que le site que que le système
worley après l'engagement de période
d'engagement de négociation se fait que
certainement votre corps avec l'argent
nécessaire à la transition
mais jusqu'à date c'est trop loin pour
concerner le monde puisque nous de ce
que demandait en fait l'invité précédent
monsieur lesage du conseil en éducation
des premières nations il avait une
question qui vous étaient adressées est
ce que le gouvernement fédéral s'engage
formellement à s'attaquer à la pauvreté
chez les premières nations
parce que il ya ça aussi la conséquence
actuelle on vit dans une grande pauvreté
dans plusieurs communautés autochtones
là on dit oui on amène de l'argent on
amène de l'argent mais la pauvreté
elle est toujours là il ya encore des
communautés qui manquent d'eau potable
on disait d'électricité de deux produits
de base
oui comme deux choses premièrement
dans le projet de loi il va voir ça a
été très clair que la pauvreté c'est
plus une raison pour appréhender les
enfants se sait quelque chose qu'on a
entendu souvent qu'un confrère des
consultations à travers le pays qu'il
prend nos enfants parce qu'on est on est
pauvre plus on peut pas en plus nos
maisons sont plus adéquats
nono dont systèmes d'infrastructure
sopra dit quoi c'est l'horizon clip
pourquoi qui prend nos enfants ce qu'ils
peuvent plus faire ce soutien clair
principe dans le projet de loi
deuxièmement notre gouvernement dépense
est presque 17 milliards d'argent à 2 17
milliards de dollars depuis 2015 sur des
services essentiels pour dix nations
autochtones à travers le canada
c'est d'un nouvel argent souci pour les
priorités infrastructures sur un service
dans l'éducation services de santé à
services à l'enfant enfermé et puis une
nouvelle relation fiscale pour les
nations autochtones se fait qu'avec ses
investissements avec les plus grands
programmes qu'on fait alors des services
data tonnes le but c'est pour réduire la
pauvreté
non juste dans les communautés
autochtones mais dans toutes les
communautés à travers le canada
ça fait que la question de l'eau potable
on a déjà enlevé à 80 avis à nos termes
d'eau potable il y en a 65 y reste
ah c'est pas parfait mais on est plus à
moitié chemin puis on est engagés à
enlever toutes les avis dans le terme
sur nos batailles tard 2022 je crois oui
c'est pas évident parce qu'il y en a
d'autres qui se sont ajoutés d'autres
avis qui se sont ajoutés à travers ça il
ya des élections qui arrivent à
l'automne on aimerait que les résultats
soient plus rapides
on va parler de la réalité des ambiances
pardon tout le monde aimerait des
résultats plus rapides où il faut
il faut qu'on soit conscient qu'on est
en train de faire ce travail dans des
espaces très isolés on est potes inde
d'un pénalité plusieurs communautés se
fait que en en avance au point
oui alors on a beaucoup parlé de la
réalité des enfants des premières
nations avec notre première invitée avec
elisha on va parler de la réalité des
enfants inuits et je pense qu'il échappe
à plusieurs questions à vous poser
d'ailleurs à ce propos là parce que
c'est une autre façon de l'est plus dans
les domaines de santé puis on a discuté
tout à l'heure comment le président joël
ne s'applique pas aux emirates mais qu'
il ya une cadre que s'est fait poser nue
est qui ce qui était en train d'être
élaboré pour que les inuits une
programmes semblables
et puis où on y danse est processus
maintenant en septembre on a entendu
dire que sept nouveaux cas elle va
sortir entre décent mais puis février
qui viennent de passer où on lit dans
ses processus maintenant et on on une
très bonne relation avec nick à nos
bêtes qui le président de meetic et qui
représente les inuits
on sait que enfin le partenariat sur
plusieurs sujets avec lui en éducation
sayyed a dressé la crise de suicide en
inuit et puis aussi l'éducation se fait
que j'ai pas l'information devant moi
comment que sur les faits précis mais je
sais qu'on a une bonne relation avec les
inuits et puis on est en train d'avancer
avec des plans solides en partenariat
avec les communautés sur la question de
jordan transports je suis fier à dire
que on a donné des services à plus qu'à
environ 220 mille jeunes premières
nations du rugby à travers le canada
ah c'est vrai ça inclut pas les ignorer
ou les médecins non plus amelio toutes
sortes de
de deux directeurs de négociations mais
dès des tribunes elle qui nous donnent
des décisions qu'on est en train de
l'étudier puis ça se peut ça se peut
qu'à l'avenir on va donner des services
en réserve dans les grandes villes
puissent as peur on est en train
d'étudier toutes les décisions est ce
que le cad pour les inuits est ce que ça
va sortir cette année
j'espère que oui je pense que ça dépend
sur sur quel hacker l'injuste
spécifiquement comparables et puis j'ai
vraiment j'ai pas cette information clé
ici pour cette entrevue mais c'est
quelque chose que je peux vous de venir
avec vos futurs
parce qu'en fait les inuits sont
dispersés sur quatre grands territoires
est ce que ça les touche de la même
manière d'un territoire à l'autre mais
c'est ce qui nous a permis de souvent
c'est que les quatre régions unis est
très connue au canada se retrouve dans
les territoires de novès le 9 août sur
le territoire mais aussi dans les
provinces ne vit que dans le nord du
québec
et puis nous nati à voûtes dans la
breloque dont la love c'est comme défaut
les besoins sans très différent selon où
se trouve la région nous et encaisse
exactement est ce qu on prend compte
justement de ces parties de ses
particularités entre les différentes
régions qui abritent les inuit une
question pour moi oui monsieur vandal
est ce que lorsque à l'isie oui oui on
est très sain sibérie les distinctions
entre les premières et les trop gros pas
cape town mais aussi des distinctions
dans des régions où notre univers de
chacun
on travaille tout proche avec un ticket
avec n'était nobel sur sur beaucoup d'un
joueur et partant éducation santé santé
infrastructures et puis aussi avec les
représentants de ces régions ici à la
chambre des communes
ça fait que on a de bonnes relations des
poteaux
sur toutes les toutes les les enjeux
mais en travaillant somme pour avancer
il est une autre question à monsieur
vandal
donc ça c'est mes questions d'accord
monsieur vandal merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir accepté de répondre à quelques
unes de nos questions avant de vous
quitter les élections fédérales arrive
bientôt
c'est un projet de loi est ce qu'il aura
le temps de devenir une loi officiel
avant les élections du mois d'octobre
sûrement pas j'ai confiance que ça va se
faire avoir conquis pour les professeurs
d'aqaba on est en haut un plan pour pour
avancer ce projet de loi au sénat puis
dans les comités nécessaire et je suis
conscient que ça va devenir projet de
loi voilà l'espérons également merci
beaucoup monsieur vandal d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je le rappelle vous êtes
le secrétaire parlementaire du ministre
des services aux autochtones monsieur
seamus o'regan daniel vandal à très
bientôt merci merci beaucoup
alors on va changer de sujet maintenant
il reste quelques minutes à l'émission
et puis charles et là on va pas
l'ignorer le pauvre mais charles vous
nous parlez pas des enfants
non bon parce que dans le monde culturel
oui il ya des spectacles qui touche aux
enfants autochtones mais pas dans le cas
qui nous concerne et on voulait parler
d'actualité et on voulait parler d'une
artiste incontournable
caroline monnaie exactement car elle une
manette est une artiste
multidisciplinaire a été la soeur de
l'autre en fait oui ça c'est la salle de
mm lors de ma première année qu'on avait
fait j'avais fait ça a été c'était le
sujet de ma chronique mais aux artistes
talentueux c'est incroyable écoute
pour ce qui est de carole et de monet
commencé ses études en sociologie et en
communication puis à se diriger vraiment
d'une manière autodidacte verts
valaisans
donc c'est assez partie une carrière par
elle-même tant au niveau des heures à le
présenter au palais au palais de tokyo à
paris berlin à la gatineau ou aux
galeries nationales d'ottawa musée d'art
campanaire montréal si on la voit ici
donc elle a fait le tour du monde l'a
fait des jaloux du monde et je pêche
communiquer avec elle envisage suis pas
connu ça va me permettre d'être des
prévenus mais câline je crois que je
crois que ça prend lé beaucoup de et
très humble oui oui j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant et puis c'est une superbe
belle visibilité pour un artiste de par
chine d'aller pouvoir exposer dans une
dans une aussi une biennale prestigieuse
aurait bien alba et on s'entend que
cette année-là whitney biennale
c'est une exposition qui regroupe 75
artistes dont deux sont canadiens et
autochtone en plus on puisse la deuxième
il s'agit d'un tir zac athènes qui est
d'origine
originaire de regina et de vis
présentement par ont tous une
réalisatrice ou six artistes performeurs
écrivains et les de la nation créé les
limites sociales avec des cassettes donc
l'a16 écrit donc ce c2d portrait là
qu'ils ont été invités à participer à la
7e biennale faisant de la biennale c'est
quoi exactement donc elle se déroule au
whitney museum of american art à new
york qui cède biennale qui durent quoi
de mai à septembre exactement du 7 mai
au 22 septembre cette année
et donc voilà c'est cécilia et plusieurs
volets dans le dal
dans la biennale d'ailleurs comment que
c'est fait comment s'est fait approcher
j'aimerais bien qu'à l'aller elle avait
été approchée par sky opine cas qui est
un artiste
en arts visuels ou c'est un art de la
vidéo c'est lui qui s'occupe
c'est lui qui était mandatée pour un
voile et vidéos qui vont être présentés
en septembre lors de la biennale et elle
a deux oeuvres qui figuré par
l'entremise de cette rencontre le ça lui
a permis d'avoir une invitation pour
pour pour la biennale pour moi pour
faire partie de l'exposition permanente
donc c'est avec joie qu'elle a accepté
cccc la vague d'amour qu'elle ait reçu
face à tout ça donc c'est pour elle une
fierté aussi de pouvoir de pouvoir
conquérir ou si le marché américain
parce que bon on s'entend que c'est le
marché octg d'art autochtone est très
peu connue bon commence à se faire
connaître un peu partout dans le monde
comme qu'on peut le voir
donc moi je pense que c'est une belle
opportunité pour elle de pouvoir les
toucher ce marché le qui a laissé son 6e
marché le du bout des doigts
combien de ces oeuvres vont y être
présentés alors pendant la biennale en
fait trois de ses oeuvres vont être
présentés durant la biennale
on parle des oeuvres qui traitent de
sujets on parle de montrer une image
positive des premières nations que la
dualité entre les langues le français
l'anglais
les dualités que les deux survivants
fait sénat en tant qu'auto tentant
quelques mythes afin que que non
autochtone aussi les deux identités qui
vivent entre eux et les langues en cette
année internationale des langues de
tonnes soit exactement donc cédé 18 tic
et leur présence et dualité de la au
travers de son oeuvre donc
donc voilà je lui ai posé la question
j'ai dit senti une pression
sentez vous une pression de par rapport
à celle de créer quelque chose à me dit
non pour l'instant c'est des offres qui
est qu'elle avait des jeunes en sont
dans son portfolio qui avait présenté
et puis donc voilà ça y avait une
pression de produire quelque chose de
pour la biennale
cependant elle ça valait bien le toronto
en septembre où elle devra créer une
oeuvre selon selon un thème particulier
c'est ça qui est vraiment partout et par
tous en même temps c'est vraiment c'est
une artiste qui qui mérite d'être vu et
reconnu pour son travail
on est donc contemporain toujours à le
faire elle a fait une a vraiment donné
quitus ce sont des créations vidéo
principal
oui vidéo vidéo même installe hâtive
donc on joue un peu d'en bas dans la
multidisciplinarité de tout sauter la
table avec elle et flèches dessus c'est
extraordinaire donc c'est désert pour
moi qui me touche et qui ont plusieurs
sens c'est une belle communication entre
les deux mondes et du monde tout seul
aujourd'hui donc oui donc deux
autochtones il ya caroline vous disiez
monnaie il ya sept sur quatre à
découvrir à la whitney biennale de new
york donc du mois de mai au mois de
septembre
voilà merci beaucoup charles mercier
liche
merci à vous deux alors je vous dis tout
de suite on se prépare pour la semaine
prochaine ont pas ou des femmes parce
que la semaine prochaine c'est le 8 mars
donc incontournable c'est la journée
internationale des femmes et nous allons
nous intéresser aux femmes autochtones
donc préparez vos sujets voilà merci à
vous aussi alors normalement nous aurons
deux invités la semaine prochaine je ne
vous donne pas tout de suite leur nom
mais nous allons nous promener entre
deux générations de femmes autochtones
alors soyez si la semaine prochaine avec
nous pour ce 8 mars
à très bientôt au revoir
[Musique]
oh